everybody is super bummed out that
spider-man may no longer be a part of
the MCU but today we have some hope
what's up everyone it's Warren and
lately all anybody could talk about or
think about is this Spider Man Disney
Sony deal is Spider Man going to remain
in the MCU or is the Disney Sony deal
going to fall through and spider-man go
back to Sony in their spider-verse I
recently asked you all in a poll and it
seems like everybody wants spider-man to
stay in the MCU and luckily for us it
seems like there's hope we have a recent
report from an insider that is in the
industry who also reported the original
news about spider-man entering the MCU
so he's somebody who has been right in
the past about spider-man big time and
according to him we should not give up
hope yet on spider-man remaining in the
MCU so let's break down everything he
said quick reminder if you'd like a
chance to win an Xbox one or ps4 be sure
to subscribe to my channel like this
video and comment with your favorite
superhero or villain also yesterday I
launched my personal channel culture
captains it's a comedy channel and would
love it if you went over and sub to it
so we have a report from industry
insider Mike Sutton now for those of you
who don't know who Mike is in 2015 he
was the one who originally reported that
Disney and Sony were making a deal for
spider-man to be in the MCU which of
course he was right about he also
dropped the fact that he would be in
civil war as well and which of course he
was right about again so Mike does have
credit when it comes to spider-man and a
recent report from Mike says that Disney
and Sony are working on a new deal and
it's very close to being done and could
be announced this week he recently
reported this on Facebook and he said I
am hearing from sources inside Sony and
Disney that both sides might reach a new
agreement in a week's time more or less
now he did note in his report that
nothing is official or set in stone
which that's how it is with deals and
agreements they can always change in
fact that's what happened with Sony and
Disney to put them in the spot
Sony and Disney had a deal for
spider-man to appear in the MCU and then
all of a sudden they didn't but the good
news is that according to Mike Sony and
Disney are on the verge of working up a
new agreement an agreement that will
allow spider-man to remain in the MCU
and although it's not confirmed
spider-man being in the M
you is something that is really good for
both Sony and Marvel so they're probably
doing everything they can to come to an
agreement especially after hearing all
of the fans negative reactions to
spider-man no longer being in the MCU so
Sony knows that it's a good thing for
spider-man to remain in the MCU which
entices them to make a deal and again
according to Mike Sutton Disney and Sony
are going back and forth but it's
looking very positive right now and Mike
was 100% right about spider-man being in
the MCU before back in 2015 so it looks
like there's some hope so let me know
what you think about this news how
excited would you be to have spider-man
remain in the MCU be sure to let me know
in the comments down below and also
don't forget to comment with your
favorite superhero or villain like this
video and subscribe to my channel so you
can stay up to date on everything
relating to the MCU and so you can enter
my giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
one or a ps4 and again I just launched
my personal channel culture captains and
would love it if you went over and sub
to it don't forget to follow me on
Twitter and Instagram and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof